l'association turco européennes milica
russe a obtenu un permis de construire
pour une école située à albertville
alors qu'elle a refusé de signer la
nouvelle charte des principes pour
l'islam de france
le député les républicains guillaume
pelletier demande alors au gouvernement
de dissoudre cette association pour
cette raison on peut effectivement
dissoudre une association c'est prévu
par le code de la sécurité intérieure
mais c'est là que guillaume lepennetier
se trompe on ne peut dissoudre que les
associations liées à des actes de
terrorisme ou qui incitent à la
discrimination à la haine voire à la
violence c'est ce qui est arrivé au
collectif contre l'islamophobie en
france le ccf qui a été dissous fin 2020
ou à génération identitaire plus
récemment dissoute en mars 2021 à droite
cette idée n'est pas nouvelle déjà en
2017 françois fillon ont réclamé la
dissolution de toute association qui se
réclament du salafisme
or si on commence à dissoudre des
associations pour motifs politiques ou
idéologiques
on met le doigt dans un engrenage
infernal un gouvernement de gauche pour
être ainsi dissoudre une association
seulement parce qu'elle est trop à
droite à son goût il est toujours facile
de proposer dans l'émotion et
l'indignation des mesures qui paraissent
être de bon sens pour ses électeurs mais
un responsable politique ne doit jamais
oublier qu'il ne fait pas des lois
seulement pour son parti mais aussi pour
l'opposition qui demain pourrait être
majoritaire et pourrait bien retourner
sa loi contre lui